bladesmiths this is the strength test
the wooden ramrod chop
to test the strength and durability of
your edge as well as the overall
construction of your knives i'll be
chopping into this ramrod 10 times
bob you're up first you ready
no but let's do it steel is a finicky
little critter sometimes it works real
good sometimes it just snaps in your
face you'll never know until you test it
and there she goes
[Music]
feel like a punch in a gut well bob
quite obviously your blade broke
bob your blade suffered a critical
failure the very first strike of the
very first test
oops for that reason i have to ask you
to please leave the forge
if you've never broken a blade as a
bladesmith you have a bladesmith
i have no regrets this is merely a
stumbling block when you're walking down
the street you get up you dust yourself
off and you move on i came here to prove
that i can make a knife under strenuous
conditions in three hours i did that
win or lose i did that
late smiths welcome to the keel test
your boujas look beautiful but are they
deadly well to find that out i will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
two
big carcasses
all right benton are you ready to hand
it out ready to rock and roll let's do
this
i've never made this style of weapon
before i've never been able to test this
kind of construction i just don't know
how it's going to hold up
[Music]
oh
man
well ben any warrior knows that if you
leave a piece of shrapnel that big at a
target it's deadly however a warrior
also knows that his weapon needs to be
strong and your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our very first
test
and therefore you cannot move forward in
this competition
come on brother did a great job man
i feel pretty bummed but this challenge
has been both very difficult in
invigorating at the same time i've made
things that i've never
made before
and i've overcome some challenges that
i've never had to face before so overall
it was a great experience
all right bladesmiths for a strength
test i'm going to take your sabers
and i'm going to beat them and stab them
into these field obstacles
now i'm not really concerned about what
your swords do to our obstacles i want
to see the opposite what they do to your
swords hey feeling chris good as it can
be sir all right
this test is about as extreme and
brutally abusive as you can put a weapon
through
i'm feeling pretty nervous
[Music]
that right here
lucky day
chris your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our strength
test and unfortunately
you cannot continue with testing which
means you cannot be the forest fire
champion
please exit the forge come on forward
path
i did have a small issue when it got to
my heat treat
that's right i didn't want to risk a
second quench because i didn't want to
make it overly brittle i do have some
regret about that decision at this point
of course i would like to be the fortune
fire champion but i am really proud of
myself as a weapons maker and i plan on
getting right back in my forge when i
get home and i'm going to move forward
as ever
to test the strength and durability of
your kellowangs i am going to chop into
them
remember this test is all about what
they do to your callawang and not what
your colorwaynes do to them until you're
up first you ready where is i'm gonna
get
[Music]
hunter your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure and can no longer
continue with testing for that reason i
have to dismiss you from the forge
i'm feeling pretty disappointed i don't
know i just thought it was going to be
more solid than that if i could start
over again i'd make the blade a little
wider a little thicker and make sure i
didn't have a stress point in it
i still want to go full time
i've definitely learned a lot
everybody to make from now on is going
to be better
welcome to the strength test
obviously the ice block chop
i'm gonna take your completed knives and
i'm going to smash them quite vigorously
and enthusiastically into these big
chunks of ice 10 times
ron how you feeling a little nervous
it's all right i'm not nervous it'd be
okay
oh run this is definitely a big issue
here material sheared right away from
the
sprocket steel here
ron your blade has suffered a
catastrophic blade failure in our
strength test unfortunately that means
that your blade did not make the cut i
have to ask you to please leave the
forge thank you
being here meant a lot to me i didn't
make it all the way but when i get home
i'm gonna get all my kids give them all
a big hug and practice with some more
chain this time i won't hit the chain as
long
the saw back hunting sword as the name
implies it's used for hunting to hunt
for the kill
i'm going to take your weapon deliver
lethal blows on this ram carcass all
right devin it's your turn you ready i'm
ready
[Music]
well devin you brought us a beautiful
sword
but
it had critical failure it broke
devin i'm just gonna be direct
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
weapons failure and can't continue with
testing
in other words it doesn't make the cut
and i have to ask you to please leave
the forge
thank you
i came in here looking for the hardest
craziest challenge i could get
and i think i got it
winning would have been great second
place on fortune fire i'm happy with
that too
it's been one hell of a ride
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
i'm to do is take each of your weapons
and beat them repeatedly and viciously
into different points of this shield
ashay you're up first how you feeling
good let's do it
ashay
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure and cannot continue with testing
but that doesn't mean that you're out of
this competition
levi
your blade needs to survive at least
nine strikes on this shield
are you ready indeed sir shea are you
ready oh yeah jay nielsen are you ready
oh yeah
let's do this gents
[Music]
levi unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure on the first strike
against that shield
for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
i definitely proved why i came to prove
i wanted to be able to push myself
beyond my regular limits good job
my family at home is definitely gonna be
proud of me and i'm taking home
skills and knowledge that i didn't have
before i came here and that's definitely
a win for me
all right gentlemen what i'll do to test
the strength of your blades
is try to break through that door
now this test is not about what your
axes do to this door but what this door
does to your axes carl you ready 100
okay
okay carl i have some questions about
the construction of this head okay
was this a solid piece going from this
side to this side no it's mig welded to
the tang of the spear on the inside
because
okay that's what i didn't want to have
happen
um
carl unfortunately your weapon has
suffered a catastrophic failure in the
middle of our strength test and can no
longer be tested safely and for that
reason i have to ask you to please leave
the forge
thank you
good luck man
i'm disappointed i'm a very competitive
person but i have
absolutely 100
zero regrets
the whole idea for me is i wanted to see
what i could do and how far i could push
myself
first thing i do when i get home gonna
kiss my wife have an adult beverage and
think about what the next project is
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your blades i am going to be bashing
your knives with a baton into these
copper pipes
mercilessly
remember this test is all about what the
pipes do to your blades and not what
your blades do to the pipes derek do you
ready do it i love destructive testing
[Music]
derek unfortunately you suffered a
catastrophic blade failure after only
five strikes on the copper pipe
you cannot continue with testing and for
that reason i have to ask you to please
leave the forge
hey it was so great yeah i might have
heat treated a bit hot i was in a real
rush in round one
i think i did the best i could in the
time that was given me i was kind of
stressed on the floor
but
truthfully it was it was wonderful i
loved it
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your sides i've affixed them to our
forged and fire coffin
oh god and i will be batoning your edge
many many times
remember this test is all about what the
batons do to the sides and not what the
scythes do to the batons
chase you're up first you ready let's do
this
all right
as ben pulls out this ball and i'm
immediately worried about edge damage
[Music]
chase unfortunately your blade has
suffered a catastrophic weapons failure
and will no longer continue in this
competition and for that reason i have
to ask you to please shake your
competitor's hand and leave the forge
i'm very proud of my scythe it was the
best work that i possibly could have
done
i've learned a lot about myself
personally and the the ways that i work
under pressure and i had a really great
time doing all this right now it's kind
of hard to express that
but i really have had a great time
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
the antler chop
to test the strength and durability of
your celtic ring knife blades as well as
the overall construction i'm gonna be
bashing them into these antlers
jody you're up you ready
wow
jody this is a competition where the
best blades move forward and
unfortunately that catastrophic blade
failure means you can no longer continue
with testing and for that reason i have
to ask you to please leave the forge
my last 18 years in the military has
taught me anything it's adapt and
overcome
i'm probably going to make this knife
again and again just so i can prove to
myself that i can still do it
even though i'm not moving on to round
three i couldn't pick two better smith
to lose to these guys are exceptional i
wish i'm the best
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
i'm going to take each of your blades
and beat them mercilessly into these
bones
i don't really care what your blades do
the bones i want to see what the bones
do to your blades it's that time sean
how you feeling well time will tell now
here he goes
only epoxy holding this
you made the mistake of gluing your
scales on then trying to drill all the
way through and then it was too hard
so there's no mechanical connection the
stress from those three blows was enough
to pop the scale right off all right
sean unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the handle and
can no longer continue in this
competition
please leave the forge
i've always been told your worst
mistakes are your best lessons
this challenge has really been like a
baptism in fire
if i had more time i probably would have
decided to put some mechanical fastening
on that handle
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry and through
his military campaigns he revolutionized
the use of horse in military conflicts
so to test the strength and durability
of your blades i'll be chopping into
these horse skulls
all right dan are you ready no but let's
do it
everybody says that
uh
at the guard
dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test which means that we
can no longer test it
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand
and then please leave the forge
it hurts but my sword breaking it's
going to be a reminder that i have to
push harder and be better dan keep up
the work that's a good source i came
here to prove that i can compete with
the big dogs and that i do know what i'm
doing and i think i might have
accomplished that
all right basements welcome to the kill
test
the cane sword what an elegant way to
walk around with a concealed weapon
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your rocket will do i will take your
cane sword deliver killing slashes and
blows on this ballistics dummy all right
ashley it's your turn are you ready sir
absolutely let's do this
this is the kill test
and a cane sword has to kill if it
doesn't this is the end of the line
oh
there it was
bro i'm sorry
it's all right
well ashley when we have a tough break
on this show it's literal you suffered
catastrophic failure and cannot continue
in this competition and for that reason
i'd like to invite you to please leave
the range
it's
heartbreaking but i am incredibly proud
of the work that i've done
when i get home the first thing i'm
gonna do is make another cane sword
i
i gotta do it right at least once so yes
you